Capital Markets Union unlocking funding
for Europe's growth this is Anna Anna is
an entrepreneur with a brilliant idea
who's looking for funding and this is
Paul Paul as a saver looking to invest
his money unfortunately in the current
situation he's not getting much return
on his savings so he's thinking about
investing in the capital markets to get
the funding Anna needs for her small
business she can turn to friends and
family or ask for a loan from a bank
most small and medium-sized enterprises
in Europe get their funds from banks but
banks have less lending capacity since
the crisis just over a third of SMEs
failed to get the complete financing
they asked for from their banks in 2013
so where else can Anna get the funds she
needs she could get direct funding from
the capital markets this includes public
markets like shares and bonds and
private markets like private equity and
private placement unfortunately capital
markets in Europe are still
underdeveloped compared to other
economies and they are fragmented along
national lines shareholders and buyers
of bonds rarely go outside their own
country when they invest the result and
as needs for financing and polls money
never meet there is a pool of potential
funding for businesses across Europe
that's completely untapped and
integrated well regulated single market
for capital in the European Union would
improve things it would help Anna and
other businesses to raise finance more
easily and help Paul and other savers to
get more from their money that's the
goal of the capital markets union it's a
plan by the European Commission to
remove barriers to cross-border
investments diversify the funding of the
economy and reduce the cost of raising
capital in order to support economic
growth and job creation in Europe
to find out more go to this link